hi
i'm ben chancefield and i'm graduating
from the department of american studies
with my doctorate
i'm a historian of race and capitalism
with a focus on u.s cities
and cultural studies of the built
environment and i'm a 2021 winner of the
field prize for my dissertation
born in flames arson racial capitalism
and the reinsuring of the bronx in the
late 20th century
subordinate flames examines the wave of
landward arson that coursed
through the bronx and scores of other
u.s cities in the 1970s
though commonly confused with the
uprisings of the 60s
these fires were wet not for protest but
for profit
most of which floated to the ironically
named fire industries that's finance
insurance and real estate
so by asking why cities went up in
flames in these years
how their fires were extinguished and
what arose in their ashes
the project casts new light on the
restructuring of u.s cities over the
past
five decades i track how the turn
towards financialization reached its
peak right in the aftermath
of the civil rights movement's heyday
and ask what the coinciding nature
of those two formations can tell us
about this moment
in the history of race and capitalism
at the center is the study of a state
subsidized fire insurance program that
was initiated as a direct response to
the uprisings of the 60s
ostensibly intended to end insurance
redlining the program was more of a
bailout for
the insurance industry and it
inadvertently incentivized landlords to
set their buildings on fire
through a study of the bronx known as
the arson capital of the
of the world in these years i chronicle
how black and latinx tenants mobilize
dozens of anti-arson organizations
that by the early 1980s stunned the tide
of the burnings
and then a final threat of the project
turns an eye to the cultural responses
to the buyers by considering how
the ubiquity of the fire trope in films
fiction and popular music of the era
from
the towering inferno to disco inferno
offers a hidden transcript for contested
interpretations of the arsenal wave
these various threads weave together a
story about risk
real estate and power in an era when
race and race thinking
were undergoing profound shifts thanks
hi my name is stefano daniele and i
graduated
in december 2020 with a phd from the
department of neuroscience
my work focuses on global brain ischemia
or in other words
how the brain responds to interruptions
in blood flow such as in the case of
cardiac arrest
i'm a 2021 porter prize winner and my
submission
is entitled ex vote norma thermic
restoration of circulation and cellular
functions in the large mammalian brain
hours post-mortem
now to place my phd work in context
traditional understanding maintains that
the brain is highly vulnerable to
interruptions in blood flow
tolerating only several minutes of
circulatory arrest
before undergoing widespread and
irreversible loss of cellular viability
however over the past century multiple
lines of observation
have brought into question the finality
of cellular viability
minutes or even hours after death in the
large mammalian brain
therefore the central question i asked
in my phd work was
how long after prolonged global ischemia
do cells within the large mammalian
brain remain viable
now to test this question my colleagues
and i developed a novel technology
called brainx
which consists of three components the
first of which
is a circulatory device that is
comprised of a variety of membranes
pumps and tubes that mechanically mimic
many of the functions of the heart the
lungs
and the kidney the second is a uniquely
formulated
blood analog solution that is entirely
synthetic
acellular and is supplemented with a
cocktail of protective agents
to prevent cell death and promote
recovery from prolonged periods of
ischemia and the third is a surgical
procedure
to isolate the brain from the skull
allowing us to connect it to the
circulatory device
now utilizing this system my colleagues
and i
observed that circulation and cellular
functions
can be restored in the large mammalian
brain up to four
hours after death now these findings
indicate that cells in the large
mammalian brain
retain a greater resilience to
lack of blood flow than was once
appreciated
and importantly these findings may help
lay the groundwork for the development
of novel therapies
to salvage brain tissue function in
patients
suffering from devastating conditions
such as cardiac arrest
and stroke i thank you so much for your
time
and i thank the porter prize committee
for this honor
and i continue wishing you health and
safety
during this difficult period thank you
again my name is zuri sullivan and i
earned my phd in immunobiology in
december 2020.
i'm fascinated by how the immune system
helps animals adapt to different
environments
i'm a 2021 winner of the porter prize
and
my prized submission was entitled food
quality control
nutrition and immunity in intestinal
homeostasis
the gastrointestinal tract is a
multi-kingdom
cellular ecosystem that facilitates the
procurement of nutrients from the
environment
it is in constant contact with the
outside world
and is therefore simultaneously a point
of encounter
with life-threatening pathogens and
toxins
and the site of absorption for
life-sustaining nutrients
consequently the intestine is tasked
with the challenge
of balancing its primary functions of
nutrient uptake
bringing things in with host defense
keeping things out
in response to a complex and constantly
changing environment
this challenge is particularly daunting
for omnivores like ourselves
whose diets change on daily seasonal and
lifelong time scales
alongside encounters with ingested
toxins enteric pathogens
and trillions of commensal microbes
omnivorous lifestyles therefore require
that the gi tract be adaptable to the
dynamic nature of our
environments my doctoral studies
examined the cellular and molecular
mechanisms that confer this adaptability
using mice as a model system i
discovered that the machinery
involved in the digestion and absorption
of carbohydrates was induced on demand
in response to a high carb diet
this on-demand induction involved
changing the cellular composition of the
intestinal epithelium
demonstrating that the gi tract can
undergo rapid
tissue remodeling in response to
different diets
and my most surprising discovery was
that a specific type of immune cell
called gamma delta t cells was required
for this intestinal adaptation to
carbohydrates
this was the first demonstration that an
immune cell can directly regulate
nutrient uptake
in the intestine and has established an
entirely new area of research
pertaining to the connection between
nutrition and immunity
by linking nutrient uptake and host
defense at the cellular and molecular
levels
these adaptations conferred by the
immune system enable this complex tissue
to adjust the balance between nutrient
uptake and host defense
in response to environmental change
thank you very much and congratulations
to all of the graduates